let's say that we have the sum
one
minus one plus one minus one
plus one and just keeps going on and on
and on like that forever and we can
write that with sigma notation this
would be the sum
from n is equal to one lowercase n
equals one to infinity we have an
infinite number of terms here of let's
see this first one we want it to be a
a positive one and then we want to keep
switching terms so we could say this is
negative 1
to the lower case n
minus 1 power let's just verify that
that works when n is equal to 1 it's
negative 1 to the 0 power which is that
when n is equal to 2 it's 2 minus 1 it's
negative 1 to the first power that's
equal to that right over there so this
is a way of writing
this series now what i want to think
about is
does this series converge to an actual
finite value
or and there's another way of saying
it's like what is this sum is the is
there a finite sum that we can say is
equal to this right over here or does
this series diverge and the way that we
can think about that is by thinking
about its partial sums
let me write that down
the partial
the partial sums
of this series and the way we could
define the partial sums so we'll give an
index here so capital n
so the partial sum
is
going to be the sum from n equals 1 but
not infinity but to capital n of
negative 1 to the n minus 1. so just to
be clear what this means so the
the partial sum with just one term is
just going to be from n lowercase n
equals 1 to uppercase n equals 1. so
it's just going to be this first term
right over here it's just going to be 1.
the
s sub 2
s sub 2 is going to be equal to 1 minus
1. it's going to be the sum of the first
two terms
s sub 3
s sub 3 is going to be 1 minus 1
plus 1. it's the sum of the first three
terms which is of course equal to
equal to let's see this is equal to one
this one over here is equal to
is equal to zero
s sub four we could keep going s sub
four is going to be one minus one plus
one minus one which is equal to zero
again
so once again the question is does this
sum converge to some finite value
and i encourage you to pause this video
and think about it given what we see
about the partial sums right over here
so in order for a series to converge
that means that the limit an infinite
series to converge that means that the
limit
the limit so if your convergence
convergence is the same thing is the
same thing as saying that the limit
as
capital as the limit as capital n
approaches infinity of our partial sums
is equal to some finite let me just
write like this is equal to some finite
finite value
so what is this limit going to be
well let's see if we can write this so
this is going to be let's see s sub n if
we want to write it in general terms we
already see if if s if if capital n
is odd it's equal to one if capital n is
even it's equal to zero so we could
write
let's write this down so s sub n i could
write it like this
it's going to be 1
if
n
odd
it's equal to 0
if
n
even
so what's the limit as s sub n
approaches infinity so what's the limit
what's the limit
as n approaches infinity of s sub n
well this limit doesn't exist it keeps
oscillating between these points you
give me you you go one more it goes from
one to zero you give me one more it goes
from zero to one so it actually is not
approaching a finite value so this
this right over here
does not exist
does
not
exist it's tempting because it's bounded
it's only it's all it keeps oscillating
between one and zero but it does not go
to
one particular value as n approaches
infinity so here we would say that our
series s
diverges
r series s
di
diverges